Змушували і гімн російський співати, змушували російською говорити,
але ми все одно намагалися українською.
А коли нас змушували гімн співати - ми читали "Отче наш" і 50-ий та 90-ий псалом.
Щоправда, після цього нас били.
Так про своє перебування у російському полоні згадує священник-капелан Василь Вирозуб.
На другий день повномасштабного вторгнення він вирушив на острів Зміїний,
щоби забрати тіла прикордонників, яких вважали загиблими.
Саме тих, кому належить легендарна фраза.
"Рускій воєнний корабль, іді на х*!"
Утім, до Зміїного отець Василь так і не доплив.
Українське судно "Сапфір" зупинили росіяни.
26 числа о 7-ій ранку нам був даний наказ з цього крейсера "Москва",
який вже підводний човен, який вже на дні Чорного моря.
Була дана команда зупинитися, кинути якір, і на борт вступила оглядова група.
Нас всіх вивели на борт, поставили на коліна, руки за голову.
І звідти вже почалися допити: чому ми сюди прийшли, навіщо нам ті тіла.
Нам казали, що всі живі, що вони всі здалися. Але ми не вірили.
Далі команду українського судна перевезли до тимчасово окупованого Криму.
Нас одразу посадили на їхню військово-морську гауптвахту.
І ми там пробули 11 діб. Там і почалися допити.
По 3-4 допити на день, по годині, по дві.
І одні й ті самі питання:
яка розвідка, з яким завданням прийшов на Зміїний, в якій розвідці служиш,
на яке відділення і в якому відділі СБУ працюєш.
Всі одні й ті самі питання.
Тільки в нас там був дуже великий психологічний тиск.
Нас там ще не били, нас там не катували.
Катувати почали після того, як отця Василя із іншими полоненими перевезли до Бєлгородської області.
Там вже почали травити і собаками, там почали вже кийками бити, там вже катували і голодом, і холодом.
Там вже виривали нігті під час допиту, ставили на розтяжки, били електрошокером.
Також було таке, що кинули в карцер, вони називали його "резінка",
приміщення десь 2,5 на 3 метри, оббите гумою.
Витяжки нема, холодно, бо це підвальне приміщення, холодно десь плюс 7-8 градусів.
Розділи догола і туди кинули. Ні води, ні їжі.
І це практично 3 з половиною доби так морили голодом і спрагою, і холодом,
бо ти заснути не міг, ти стояв, бо було холодно.
Сліди російського полону залишаються на тілі отця Василя й дотепер.
Цвях засовували під цей ніготь, а потім зірвали повністю ніготь.
Це якраз під тортурами запхали…
Та попри усі випробування отець Василь не втратив оптимізму.
Але нічого, ніготь відріс.
І Крим повернемо, і Луганськ, і Донецьк, і Бєлгородську область.
У російському полоні отець Василь провів 70 днів.
Каже, увесь цей час росіяни катували не лише фізично, а й морально.
Казали, що Одеса вже їхня, вони вже Одесу захопили,
що України вже нема, що Зеленський вже втік за кордон.
Але ми краєм вуха слухали, бо одна зі змін охоронців
приходила з невеликим радіо, і вони самі слухали новини.
Вони там Скабеєву слухали, всіх пропагандистів.
І ми пам'ятаємо перше таке повідомлення: "Мінусова плавучість крейсера Москва".
І коли ми це вперше почули, що "мінусова плавучість",
то ми зрозуміли, що він потонув.
І ми там почали кричати "Ура! Ура! Слава Україні!".
І знову нас били.
І ми вирішили, що чим гірше до нас ставляться, чим більше нас б'ють,
тим більше перемог у наших солдатів на передовій.
6 травня 2022-го року отець Василь та ще сорок військових і цивільних полонених
повернулися до України в рамках обміну.
Коли я побачив вже нашого солдата, нашого медика,
в нього прапорець на рукаві, на шевроні, жовто-синій прапор,
і каже: "Слава Україні!", - сльози пішли.
Відповісти в дійсності: "Слава! Слава Україні!".
Я зрозумів, що я вже вдома. Я вже був вдома.
Після повернення в Одесу отець Василь почав займатися волонтерством.
Капелан постійно відвідує поранених українських військових у шпиталях.
Їх і причащає.
І розважає...
Ми залишилися друзями, товаришами, побратимами для наших воїнів, для наших солдатів.
Бо треба і словом порадувати, і духовно нагодувати, і посповідати, і причастити солдата.
Підтримати, усилити у вірі і дати йому наснагу для того,
щоб він зі зброєю в руках боронив нашу Україну.
Також капелан відспівує полеглих українських захисників.
Таким чином, каже, віддає шану військовим, а також підтримує їхніх рідних.
Найбільш тяжка місія в капеланстві - це похорони.
І найбільш складно, знайти слова, щоб утішити батька і матір, які втратили сина.
Знайти ті слова, щоб утішити дружину, в якої немає чоловіка.
Або ще складніше дивитися в очі маленької дитини, 6-7 років, яка втратила тата.
От що ти маєш сказати цій дитині, як ти її маєш утішити?
Крім того, отець Василь співпрацює з волонтерськими організаціями,
які плетуть маскувальні сітки та виготовляють інше необхідне спорядження для військових.
Капелана запрошують освятити вироби перед відправленням на фронт.
Пошли духа святого на маскувальні сітки.
І щоб вони були озброєні силою твого небесного заступництва.
І були для воїнів наших захистом. Для душ і для тіл їхніх.
Також із іншими волонтерами отець Василь опікується долею кількох бригад.
Наша 28-а та 35-а бригади, це і наші морпіхи, військово-морські сили.
Ми практично зі всіма підрозділами, які знаходяться на території Одеської області, співпрацюємо.
І кошти, і одяг, і все, що необхідно, все, що є в наших силах,
ми з усім намагаємося допомогти нашим Збройним силам України.
Отець закликає кожного, хто подивиться це відео, не залишатися осторонь, адже…
Сьогодні в Україні немає або не повинно бути цивільних. Ми сьогодні всі на війні.